so how much energy has to be given to
food to heat it up if you want to heat
up an egg by 10 degrees Celsius how many
joules does it take to to do that so the
answer to this it turns out is contained
in a simple mathematical equation a
little later on I'm going to try to
convince you that if you know how to use
it properly you have the opportunity to
cook a perfect egg without investing in
a you know rather expensive immersion
heater that is by understanding the
equations that we give you you you
really will have the opportunity to use
them to invent new recipes if you so
desire
now having said that as introduction let
me go into the equation the equation
says that Q equals M CP delta T so Q is
the amount of heat that you've dumped
into the food and that is a quantity
that is measured in joules M is the mass
of a food for the purposes of this
equation M should be measured in
kilograms so delta T is the temperature
difference that's the final temperature
of the food minus the initial
temperature of the food and it should be
measured in either degrees Celsius or
degrees Kelvin and finally CP is a
number that we call the specific heat of
a material it is the number that
characterizes how much something heats
up when you apply a specific amount of
heat and it is measured in the units of
joules per kilogram per degree Celsius
or degree Kelvin and this is a number
that we will give you and that actually
you know is different for different
foods so it turns out that the specific
heat for water is 4.18 joules per gram
degree Kelvin that's the specific heat
for water now water is an important
cooking material and we will talk about
it so for eggs
another important cooking material this
specific heat is about three point one
eight joules per gram per degree Kelvin
for milk it's about three point eight
five it's closer to water for beef
depending on the cut of beef it's
somewhere between two and a half and
three and a half joules per gram degree
Kelvin for air the specific heat of air
is one the specific heat of olive oil
something which is also useful for
cooking is about one point nine seven
joules per gram per degree Kelvin so
it's actually a lower specific heat by
about a factor of two than that of water
now actually those two numbers if you
think about them the specific heat of
water and the specific heat of olive oil
the fact that most foods are between
those two numbers is not an accident by
any means I mean in fact the main
ingredient of all food is water this is
something that we're going to have to
think about constantly throughout this
course it will come up again and again
in one context or another and another
important ingredient to food of course
is fat which olive oil is a fat and fats
tend to have a specific heat around too
and food you know like beef it's
somewhere between two to four and that's
essentially why it's a little more
complicated than that but that's not a
bad explanation to get us started now so
to get us started let's actually do
something let's actually do something so
I want to calculate the energy that it
takes to boil one cup of water so it
turns out that one cup of water is 237
grams and so what I want to do is start
with water that's at room temperature so
the temperature in this room is about 23
degrees Celsius and I'd like to heat it
to the boiling point which is a hundred
degrees Celsius and I'd like to know how
much energy do I have to dump in and
when you multiply this out it turns out
that the number that you get is 76
thousand two hundred and eighty joules
so that's how much energy it takes to
boil a cup of water 76210 umber in
joules so one way to think about it how
much would would it take to make this
much energy you know if you take the
energy density of wood which I already
told you is 14 mega joules per kilogram
then you can calculate for yourself that
the that the amount of wood that it
takes is seventy-six thousand two
hundred and eighty joules divided by 14
mega joules per kilogram we find that it
takes five point four grams of wood in
order to create this much energy